melancholy isn't exactly a word on
everybody's lips
but we should pay more attention to it
even seek it out from time to time
melancholy is a species of sadness that
arises when we're open to the fact that
life is inherently difficult and that
suffering and disappointment are core
parts of universal experience it's not a
disorder that needs to be cured modern
society tends to emphasize buoyancy and
cheerfulness but we have to admit that
reality is for the most part about grief
and loss
the good life is not one immune to
sadness but one in which suffering
contributes to our development
melancholy is an underused word it
doesn't mean grim and miserable
it means grasping without rage the fact
that the world is full of folly and
greed that it is rare to find in a peace
that it is hard to live comfortably with
those we love that it's very unusual to
have a career that's both financially
rewarding and morally uplifting that
many decent people have a very hard time
often sadness simply makes a lot of
sense
we learn so late about stuff
you've wasted years everyone else
you can only avoid regret by switching
off your imagination
the wisdom of The Melancholy attitude as
opposed to the bitter or angry one lies
in the understanding that the sorrow
isn't just about you that you have not
been singled out that you're suffering
belongs to humanity in general to take
that fully to heart is to become more
compassionate and less vengeful The
Melancholy facts shouldn't make us
desperate rather more forgiving kinder
and better able to focus on what really
matters while there is still time
you